teddy bridgewater the new quarterback of
the carolina panthers who is taking the
place of cam newton with a three-year 63
million dollar contract not bad for a
guy who has started six games since
january of 2016. he was introduced
yesterday by the carolina panthers and
in this day and age of the covet 19
situation the coronavirus pandemic
there's no press conference we get to
see him on video here's some of what
teddy bridgewater had to say you know
it's a unique situation for me all i
have to do is continue to be myself
last year
you know i don't want to speak on the
road and school i was too much but when
i was in new orleans i was behind the
guy
and uh
you know i knew that when drew got
injured i had big shoes built in
and i just constantly reminded myself to
just be you know be the best person in
the teddy life of me
and um by doing so it allowed me to be
you know a better teammate better
football player and a better person
all right that's teddy bridgewater being
introduced as a carolina panthers
starting quarterback do you think he's
ready to be a full-time starter again he
has two years as a starter his numbers
were never great with the vikings he was
in the shadow of adrian peterson for
much of his time in minnesota he had the
horrific knee injury in late august of
2016. he started six games since then
one was
garbage time check the box give teddy a
chance to play but last year 5-0 working
with sean payton that's a big investment
21 million a year for a guy who hasn't
played much football is he ready in your
opinion peter
i think he is mike
and i think
one of the things that teddy bridgewater
has shown
is that when you show just enough to get
people excited about you and to get
people to think that you're the real
thing when you show that
then somebody is going to get really
excited and it only takes one and mike
as i wrote my column this week
you know at the start of this free agent
period you know in in by the middle of
february
the tampa bay buccaneers
had a list of three quarterbacks and in
order the three quarterbacks who they
wanted in free agency one tom brady and
deep down they didn't think they were
getting tom brady
two teddy bridgewater and three jameis
winston
so
this was a situation where
i think i honestly thought and i think
the dance
that that the that the tan that the
tampa bay buccaneers had to play with
teddy bridgewater at the end with
bridgewater and his agent
they had to play this dance because they
really weren't positive they thought
they were getting brady but they weren't
positive and they basically had to let
him go
on
tuesday afternoon of free agency week
and so to me
when you see that level of interest
bruce arians
uh you know joe brady who obviously had
him in new orleans so what do you think
matt rule is saying joe joe tell us what
to do and so when when joe brady says i
want teddy bridgewater we're going to be
a playoff team with teddy bridgewater i
would trust joe brady especially after
seeing that he was with the saints so he
knew him and he was with joe burrow last
year at lsu i i think it's i think it's
a no doubter mike
yeah look i i agree with you completely
and i think what we saw from teddy last
year was what we were expecting to see
from teddy bridgewater in 2016 before
that knee injury and it took a couple of
years for the knee to get back to normal
it's amazing he's able to play after
that injury which was so it was just it
was as bad as a knee injury can be and
it's an inspirational story he never
gave up he never felt sorry for himself
he kept pushing and pushing he's been a
great teammate a great presence in the
locker room he's had a chance to play
and he's played well and now he finally
gets his financial reward one that i
never thought he'd get peter 21 million
a year for a guy that was 5-0 last year
and again hasn't played a whole lot of
football and he had the vikings in
position to beat the seahawks in that
open-air playoff game the last game
played outdoors before the new stadium
was open but for blair walsh shank in
the field goal he would have been the
one who took down the seahawks dynasty
in that wild card playoff game so now he
gets a chance with the carolina panthers
to turn it around and you know pretty
good division of quarterbacks drew brees
matt ryan tom brady teddy bridgewater
you could do a lot worse in the nfl
that's amazing you know it's it's
amazing when you think about some of the
matchups we're going to see i think one
of the coolest things about this is
you know you're going to see tom brady
against drew brees
twice this season which is always that
was always a great uh you know headliner
type match-up and so you're gonna see
that one twice you're gonna see drew
brees against teddy bridgewater twice
which i think obviously is very cool so
i think a lot of the things one of the
things i'm gonna do when the dust is
settled mike is i'm going to write
basically a column that is going to be
about with the new landscape
here's what we now see and i don't just
mean you know the new england patriots
without tom brady now being the number
three team in their division maybe and
again i i have no idea what i'll say or
right at that time but there's so many
things because the landslide of moves
and signings in the last two weeks
uh that have totally changed the
landscape of the nfl that have really
made it a much more interesting league
in 2020 assuming there is going to be a
2020.
you know i i need to hang my head in
shame a little bit here while i was
touting the quarterbacks of the nfc
south saying that there were four great
ones there are actually five i forgot
how could i forget taysom hill you gotta
throw we got him here
he's your guy
he's my guy he's your guy too and he's
going to be the backup apparently sean
payton says the primary backup to drew
brees this year they're not going to go
out and get another teddy bridgewater
they're just going to let it be take
some hill
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports